jimmy jean et l'économiste en chef de
desjardins il était avec nous ce soir
bonsoir
on sent que les marchés jimmy gens
réagissent pas mal à la possibilité de
la possible hausse des taux un peu plus
tôt prévu finalement de la réserve
fédérale avec des graines d'inflation
est ce qu'on est d'engager selon vous
dans une poussée d'inflation en ce
moment on est dans une poussée
d'inflation la question c'est de savoir
comme étant la durée
c'est la grande question qui brûle on
sait que des éléments en ce moment dans
la façon dont laquelle l'inflation
calculée c'est à dire une variation
annuelle on compare le même mois de
l'année à l'eau par les cas à ce temps
ci de l'année ou du métal dans les
dernières données qu'on a qui sont pour
le mode mais on met 2020 on sait l'on
connaît la situation n'étant confinement
il est pris plongée
or on est en train de comparer une
situation on revient tranquillement à la
normale avec deux chansons les prix
plongent et donc on comprend tout à fait
des pommes avec des pommes nous ferons
en sorte que ça exagère les variations
annuelles de ces éléments à la barre les
chutes des personnes qu'il faut quand
même prendre en compte certains grincent
hier au fur et à mesure si cet effet est
purement arithmétique voit s'estomper
mais il ya quand même des déploiements
plus fondamentaux niveau de l'offre et
de la demande mondiale entre août dans
les secteurs des biens qui font en sorte
qu'il ya dix ans au delà de soliris
d'avoir des présents ils vont peut-être
durer un peu plus longtemps n'est
peut-être plus longtemps que ce à quoi
les banques centrales s'attendait
évidemment on n'a pas l'expérience de on
n'a pas de précédent de sortie de crise
de jean d'ampleur qu'on a connu donc il
ya énormément d'incertitudes autour de
ça et c'est ce qui provoque une certaine
anxiété rassure je suis parce que là on
voit que la demande est forte et sera
forte
l'épargné élevée il ya des pénuries
notamment les pénuries de semi
conducteurs il ya quand même des
éléments supplémentaires qui viennent
quoi soutenir une pression
inflationniste un peu plus fort d'ici la
fin de l'année
exactement je pense que ni plus ni moins
enfants de décider grands mouvements
d'offre et de demande d'or catégorie
d'emballer vient à frodon
faut se rappeler l'année dernière quand
la pandémie a frappé les fabricants les
producteurs de matières premières et
constructeurs qu'est ce qu'on a fait a
eu le réflexe de rationaliser les
dépenses rationaliser les
investissements la capacité parce que on
s'attendait à ce que la demande
s'effondre or qu'est ce qu'on a vu avec
la manière dont les gouvernements ont
réagi pour soutenir la demande
on a vu des finances des ménages a
fortement soutenu
on a maintenu les entreprises en vie et
donc la réaction la demande s'était
complètement l'opposé de ce que
plusieurs entreprises s'attendait à une
forte hausse de la demande
particulièrement dans l'évier
parce que à cela on superpose évidemment
l'effet de confinement qui fait en sorte
que la demande va se retirer du real est
bien tout ça mis ensemble sakic sa cruze
des pénuries ça à cause des goulots
d'étranglement ça fait monter les coûts
à l'expédition dans ce sens finalement
quand on subit en ce moment et ça a des
répercussions utilement sur l'étude et
bien non c'est ça que les effets dont
j'ai parlé au début les effets
arithmétique ça ça va s'estomper déjà
dans les prochains mois mais les effets
sont qu'en plus ce rapport avec les
pénuries dans certains cas on pourrait
parler de 2022 voire même de 2020 trop
par exemple la pénurie des
semi-conducteurs des puces informatiques
qui affecte autant les produits à
informatique les l'automobile en
particulier en forte baisse de la
production manufacturière d'automobiles
au canada au mois d'avril a pour ces
raisons là ça pourrait prendre un
certain temps avant que ça se résume
donc est-ce que c'est plus sur ces
éléments là que naissent à ce que les
entreprises qui ont souffert beaucoup
des fermetures pour être tenté de
rattraper le terrain perdu et de refiler
dans les prochains mois la facture aux
consommateurs ce qui voudrait dire des
prix plus élevés à la consommation et ça
c'est une autre ambiance qu'on voit dans
beaucoup d'encre mené auprès des
entreprises donc d'en gagner sinon c'est
pas vraiment qu'on va des hausses de
prix des des pressions sur les prix des
intrants des entreprises mais souvent
les entreprises hésitent et à
consommation au consommateur parce que
la demande et fl parce que roddick des
environnements concret
7 ne le permettait pas mais lorsqu'on
voit dans les enquêtes
autant au canada qu'aux états unis ce
qui semble y avoir une plus grande
volonté de ne pas trop grande confiance
des entreprises à pouvoir retransmettre
ces aux deux pilotes vers les
consommateurs vers des acheteurs nous
c'est comme ça qu'on a un processus
d'inflation qui se met en branle
donc l'on parle de hausse des intrants
dans le code des biens mais du côté des
services de là on sait qu'on s'en revers
lundi confinés dans des jarres et
confinement donc là il va avoir la
demande entre autres pour les
travailleurs ils ont reparlé des
pénuries de bien mais il ya eu aussi une
pénurie de travailleurs et est-ce qu'on
va être capable de ramener des gens
travail assez rapidement
s'il sent qu'on va devoir aussi les
salaires et saucisses et un coût
additionnel doit falloir peut-être
transmettre à part les primes donc c'est
aussi une fonction d'incertitudes qui
fait en sorte que au niveau des
anticipations au temps des marchés
financiers que des particuliers ou des
entreprises ont là une augmentation aux
anticipations d'inflation donc l'on peut
dire que c'est une une niveau danse
passion et inquiète à l'heure actuelle
mais clairement comparer ce qu'on voyait
dans le dernier cycle les anticipations
sont nettement plus haut merci jimmy
gens très intéressants à la prochaine on
prend plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh